اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مئات القتلى والف الجرحى
في جنوب تركيا جراء زلزال قوته سبع درجات
وسبعه عشر درجه على مقياس رختر اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ تحذر من نشاط زلزالين
خطير في منطقه كهرمان مراش مع توالي
الهزات الارتداديه القويه والرئيس التركي
يقول ان كارثه الزلزال هي الاكبر منذ عام
1939 وفي سوريا تجاوز عدد ضحايا الزلزال
الذي ضرب محافظه حلب وادلب واللاذقيه وحما
وطرطوس مئات القتلى والجرحى والدفاع
المدني يعلن شمال غرب سوريا منطقه منكوبه
ويحذر من النقص في الامكانيات ويناشد دول
العالم للاسراعي في تقديم المساعدات
في سياق ذاته اعلنت دول عده تضامنها مع
المنكوبين كما بدات دول اخرى بارسال فرق
انقاذ الى تركيا حيث اعلن حلف شمال
الاطلسي حشد الدعم واعلنت قطر انطلاق اولى
رحله جسر الجوي الى تركيا كما اعرب الدول
كالصين وروسيا وايران عن استعدادها
لمساعده الضحايا في كل من الدولتين الى
اللقاء